aus der tägliche show down nämlich
zwischen autofahrern und fahrradfahrern
immer wieder kommt es zu unfällen und
auch heftigen konfrontationen so auch in
diesem fall
mit viel zu wenig abstand fährt ein suv
an einem fahrradfahrer im siegerland
vorbei hier sehen wir die bilder der
biker beschwert sich mit einer hand
geste der autofahrer hält an und
versucht den radfahrer zu schnappen sein
kollege fünf das ganze mit seiner
helmkamera jedoch nach dieser attacke
geht es erst richtig los das auto nimmt
die verfolgung auf wechselt die fahrspur
und jagt den fahrradfahrer unmittelbar
nach der verfolgungsjagd kommt es zur
konfrontation
nein
das war gar nichts
natürlich geht gar nicht weil das
menschenleben nur gefährdet
menschenleben
zu gefährden menschenleben ja auch
wirklich zu nutzen
wer bist du
bist du hier
getrennt die zu dass du man gewinnt
heftigste emotionen auto gegen fahrrad
es ist immer das gleiche der autofahrer
gibt dem fahrradfahrer der schuld und
der fahrradfahrer dem autofahrer zwei
personen bei denen das auch zutrifft
sind der leidenschaftliche fahrradfahrer
kai feldhaus und von auto bild unser
kollege jan meno gepard was waren eure
krassesten erlebnisse ich kann bin ich
dieses video sehen sie mich nackenhaare
auf und werden als weiß ich weil dann so
erinnerungen hoch poppen ich fahre jeden
morgen 30 minuten mit dem fahrrad zur
arbeit quer durch berlin einfach was mit
dem auto nicht machbar ist nicht
umweltverträglich nicht vernünftig es
vergeht kaum ein morgen an dem man nicht
in eine zumindest bedrohliche situation
gerät wir haben das mal gefilmt können
wir uns gleich mal anschauen kannst ja
mal kommentieren wenn du die bilder
sieht wir haben sich auf dem weg zur
arbeit begleitet und du hast auch mit
einer kamera gefilmt genau ich habe mir
eine kamera um den bauch geschnallt und
bin dann mal durch kreuzberg gefahren
und durch mitte um mal zu dokumentieren
was da passiert zugelegt zugeparkte
radwege
busspuren die wir uns teilen dürfen mit
linienbussen reisebussen taxen autos
hier zugewachsene radwege was auch immer
gern genommen ist sehr voll gepackte
straßen und da hat man dann die wahl
fahre ich jetzt so nah an den parkenden
autos vorbei das mich da eine tür um
haut wenn sie aufgeht oder fahre ich so
weit auf der straße dass die
vorbeiziehenden autos mich um mangeln
also ist immer so ein tanz auf der
rasierklinge den wir da jeden morgen
werde ich berlin verkennt dass da zu
absolvieren haben da ein besonders
interessantes abenteuer erleben durfte
dass autos einfach mal rechts abgebogen
der klassiker wenn ich da nicht aufpasst
dann hat er mich hat auf der motorhaube
und so ging es hat den ganzen vormittag
da gab es ungefähr ein dutzend vorfälle
die wir dokumentiert haben und jedes mal
hätte das auch schiefgehen aber mal
ehrlich gesagt jetzt hältst du dich wenn
immer an die regeln also meine
erlebnisse im berufsverkehr hier in
berlin ist natürlich die fahrradfahrer
fahren natürlich dürften zum beispiel
die ar umgekehrt in einbahnstraßen
reinfahren an dass autofahrer bist du
oftmals mit der situation auch
überfordert die kommen auch angeschossen
und halten sich natürlich für diejenigen
die immer im recht sind ich versuche es
ich habe auch viele dieser strecken mein
sohn dabei den muss ich halten die
vorbild sein das heißt an roten ampel
angehalten es wäre sich an die
verkehrsregeln gehalten aber genauso wie
es unter autofahrern idioten gibt gibt
es natürlich auch unser fahrradfahren
idioten in frage
irgendwelche idioten hast du kennen
gelernt naja so das größte problem ist
teilweise die genommene vorfahrt einfach
so wir stehen im auto die ganze zeit mit
einem fuß in der stadt auf der bremse
weil ich immer damit rechnen müssen dass
von rechts oder links irgendwo ein
fahrradfahrer einfach quer über schießt
ohne zu gucken wir haben dich ja auch
mal begleitet und zwar auf dem heimweg
das war der weg zur arbeit du bist nach
hause gefahren und das schauen uns auch
mal an was du so erlebt hast
genau ohne zu gucken über die straße
größte problem mit den fahrradfahrern im
stadtverkehr ist vor allen dingen in
großstädten wie in berlin dass viele
einfach keinen führerschein haben sie
kennen also die wichtigsten
verkehrsregeln nicht
ohne nach hinten zu gucken fährt sie auf
die straße wenn jetzt das kind drauf ist
und sie übersieht ein auto dann ist
nicht nur sie am boden sondern auch
wahrscheinlich das kind tot
fahrradanhänger wo kinder darin
transportiert werden finde ich im
straßenverkehr übrigens richtig
gefährlich vor allen dingen dann wenn
ich in dem höheren es wie zb sitze und
rechtsabbieger schnell ist so ein
anhänger übersehen und das kind liegt
unter dem auto
ich darf jeden fall radfahrer nur mit
einem mindestabstand von 15 metern
überholen ab 90 km h muss ich sogar zwei
meter einhalten auch wieder ein schönes
beispiel ich kann keine 1,5 meter
sicherheitsabstand zum überholen
einhalten allerdings haben wir rechts
wunde aber ausgebaut hat wie
sie fahren ohne licht
rechts vor links sie natürlich auch
fremd wie soll es auch anders sein sie
fahren in der regel kein auto das sind
unsere radfahrer im straßenverkehr
[Musik]
das duell also mir geht's so ehrlich
gesagt meine damen und herren wenn ich
mit dem fahrrad unterwegs bin ich voll
auf der seite der fahrradfahrer wenn ich
mir im auto unterwegs bin bin ich voll
auf der seite der autofahrer jetzt will
ich gespannt wie dieses duell ausgeht
kai gegen jan o fahrradfahrer gegen
autofahrer will exemplarisch für viele
in deutschland also du hast ein paar
sehr interessante punkte angesprochen in
dem beitrag demokrat gesehen haben zum
beispiel diesen wenn du in einem großen
suv sitz und abbiegst dann siehst du den
anhängern nicht da stellt sich mir die
frage warum musst du denn mit einem
riesigen suv durch die stadt fahren
warum ist das denn nötig warum kann man
den nicht stehen lassen um die strecken
die hits absolvieren sind berlin ist eh
viel zu voll dann lasst doch die karre
stehen und nimmt fahrrad nehmen
carsharing ich komme ja nun nicht direkt
aus berlin ich fahre von hamburg her und
da ist es halt mal das erste mal im
geländewagen und ich kann es bei mir auf
jeden fall nicht immer abstellen nicht
mit dem scw unterwegs zu sein aber klar
des suv ist beliebt und die deutschen
mögen und von daher und ist dann ist
sofort kombi zeichnen 2008 nach berlin
gezogen ich habe schon jahre vorher mein
auto abgeschafft und mir angewöhnt mit
dem fahrrad zur arbeit zu fahren weil es
gut ist für den kopf was gutes für die
umwelt wird es ich schalte ab es wird
immer schlimmer es wird immer
anstrengender ich hab mal nachgeguckt
ich habe die zahlen angeschaut als ich
nach berlin gezogen bin gab es 1,1
millionen autos auf den straßen in
berlin jetzt sind 1,2 millionen also es
ist nicht ein einziger quadratmeter
straße dazu gekommen sondern 100.000
autos mehr die um diesen platz kämpfen
ist erschließt sich mir nicht du bist
der fachmann immer die autos werden ja
auch immer größer also anstatt jetzt zu
sagen wir müssen sie jetzt reduzieren
wir müssen gucken dass wir autos
entwickeln die in die stadt passen
werden diese karten ja immer größer und
das was du gerade gesagt dass in den
beitrag ein meter fünfzig abstand also
ich bin jetzt gerade eine fahrrad
hergekommen ins studio mindestens zehn
fälle mindestens zehn wenn ich mich auf
dem radweg gefahren bin an denen sich
niemand an diesem abstand geschert hat
oder den eingehalten hat gut ich zähle
mich zu den umsichtigen fahrern
definitiv und ich versuche immer den
abstand einzuhalten wenn es nicht geht
dann bleibe ich auch definitiv dahinter
ich rege mich allerdings extrem darüber
auf wenn rechts daneben eine perfekt
ausgebautes russell ist die auch noch
zwingend verpflichtend für radfahrer ist
durch das runde blaue schild manchmal
lehrer hat damals immer als merksatz
gesagt rund und blau zwingt die sau
verkehrsregeln kennen die meisten
radfahrer nicht und vor allen dingen in
den großstädten haben wir das problem
die sind immer mit den öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln aufgewachsen ich bin in
dem kleinen dorf in ostfriesland groß
geworden da macht man ab 18 den
führerschein und dann kennt man alle
verkehrsregeln also zumindest sollte man
sie kennen und auch danach nicht
verlieren hier in der großstädten ein
fach in der schule in der zweiten
dritten klasse mal kurz
verkehrserziehung reicht für den
straßenverkehr nicht aus ich als ich bei
einem punkt stimme ich dir voll und ganz
zu
es galt alle aller die allermeisten
radfahrer glauben wenn sie sich drauf
setzen und mit können und nicht umfallen
dann können sie fahrrad fahren das hat
mit fahrradfahren können nichts zu tun
ich kann ja auch nicht auto fahren wir
hier einsetzen kann und wie das ding
angeht aber der gravierende unterschied
ist ja der wenn du nicht gut auto fahren
kannst und die hierauf jemand trifft er
nicht gut fahrrad fahren kann dann ist
total klar wer verliert das heißt
umsichtig sollten wir alle sein aber wer
auf jeden fall noch umsichtiger sein
muss ist der autofahrer weil wenn da was
schief geht dann geht hat der
fahrradfahrer drauf es gibt eine
statistik die iss 2020 extra erhoben
worden von der polizei zur zur fahrrad
situation in berlin
18 tot gefahrene fahrradfahrer in einem
jahr 2020
7868 fahrradunfälle in einem jahr das
muss man hoch ist denn nur die
angezeigten also nicht wenn mal einer
umgekippt ist sondern die bei der von
der polizei aufgenommen wurden und dann
kommt dazu dass bei fast jedem unfall an
dem ein fahrer beteiligt ist der
fahrradfahrer verletzt wird das liegt
natürlich an der art und weise wie sich
fortbewegen aber da kann man ja nicht
sagen ihr fahrradfahrer passt ja auch
nicht auf nein also man muss auch ganz
klar sagen das fahrrad hat keine
knautschzone wie das auto und natürlich
müssen wir auch im straßenverkehr gerade
als autofahrer umsichtig fahren und also
ich mache es auf jeden fall aber ich
kann auch jeden verstehen wenn dir
morgens auf dem weg zur arbeit mehrmals
die vorfahrt genommen wird es wird sich
durch die engsten gassen durch
geschlängelt ohne rücksicht auf verluste
und wenn dann auch mal der lenker an
irgendeinem auto hängen bleibt oder mein
spiegel mit abreise da wird weiter
gefahren das interessiert sie nicht also
ich glaube tatsächlich dass rücksicht
von beiden seiten kommen muss und auch
das verständnis für den jeweils anderen
dass diese ansicht teile ich aber warum
müssen wir uns denn durch diese engen
gassen schlängeln weil es keine
vernünftigen radfahrer radwege gibt du
hast gerade diesen diesem fall
angesprochen werden ein blaues schild
steht dann muss ich auf dem radweg
fahren guckt den radwegen in berlin mal
an das war ein in dem beitrag von mega
zu sehen wenn ich von hier zum studio
richtung kreuzberg fahren da gibt es ein
radweg da muss ich aufpassen dass ich
mein fahrrad in so einem schlagloch
verschwindet die sind einfach riesig ich
kann darauf nicht fand ohne mein fahrrad
kaputt zu fahren die sind zugewuchert
dieses verbundpflaster wer auch immer
auf die idee kam dass es eine gute idee
wäre radwege aus verbundpflaster zu
basteln damit breche ich mir die haxen
und wenn ich ja nicht auf dem auf dem
gehweg fahren will und darf weil die
eltern kleiner kinder weg sind dann muss
ich auf der straße fahren und dann werde
ich angehupt weil im noch immer sucht
guck mal da da ist der deutlich da sie
ja gern mal dahin versucht man dazu
laufen ohne aufzufallen für diesen fall
gibt es ja auch die sonderregelung wenn
die straßenbeschaffenheit ist nicht
zulässt kann das fahrrad auf der straße
fahren ich sehe es aber allerdings das
aus prinzip gerne auf der straße
gefahren wird ohne irgendwie meinen
radweg zu benutzen und auch das mit den
fußgängern ist ein großes problem auch
fußgänger werden ja von fahrradfahrern
gerne angegriffen und die neue klingel
ist in der regel ein schimpfwort das
dass es war erst das trifft vor allem
für berlin zu aber da auch noch mal zur
erklärung vielleicht wer durch berlin
mit dem fahrrad fährt der weiß dass es
gibt ja irre viele
kopfsteinpflasterstraßen die sind
sowieso schon per se saugefährlich fürs
fahrrad wenn ich jetzt aber eine seit 50
jahren nicht gemacht die
kopfsteinpflasterstraße haben und
daneben einen sechs meter breiten gehweg
dann fahre ich einfach meiner sicherheit
wägen auf dem gehweg natürlich
entsprechend umsichtig und die passt auf
dass ich dann jemand um fahre ich achte
auf einfahrten und hauseingänge aber
wenn ich da auf der auf der straße auf
dem kopf sondern bin ich in lebensgefahr
also ich gebe mal jetzt da rein es ist
eigentlich wie ich es empfinde auf den
straßen der radfahrer wesentlich
aggressiver wesentlich agiler als der
autofahrer und eins muss man ja auch
berücksichtigen ein autofahrer der nicht
schnell genug reagieren kann weil auch
fahrradfahrer vielleicht aggressiv sind
werden natürlich auch seines lebens
nicht mehr froh wenn er ein
fahrradfahrer die unfälle mit den
fahrradfahrern meines erachtens
jedenfalls passieren ja nicht nur durch
rücksichtslose autofahrer sondern auch
weil fahrradfahrer war halt oftmals
rücksichtslos unterwegs sind das ist
statistisch belegt also die unfälle
diese statistik die ich gerade an
geführt habe 50 prozent der unfälle sind
von fahrradfahrern herbeigeführt diese
sind die haupt oder teil für punkt aber
die andere hälfte eben von autofahrern
und
wenn das wenns 50 sind dann ist halt am
ende der nachteil für den fahrradfahrer
meist viel größer klar aber 50 50 hat
genau das was ich vorhin gesagt haben
gegenseitige rücksichtnahme ist die
einzige lösung